[Musique]
pressures and issues affecting the
mental health of young people have
increased climate
change access to
education opportunities to own or rent
an affordable home the devastation
caused by this
pandemic access to the job market
ment he is
ourure
of to break the current pattern where we
stigmati mental health and the L of life
due to it we need to do this for our
young for
[Musique]
Europe bonsoir Nightline je
t'écoute est- est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose dont tu aimerais me
parler
[Musique]
sache que je suis vraiment là pour
t'écouter qu' importe le
sujet si tu souhaites m' parler tu peux
y aller sinon c'est comme tu
[Musique]
sens on est un service composétudi et
détudi du coup on est pas
professionnel on a ététive pour vous
[Musique]
écouter d'accord
pourquoi est-ce que tu voudrais pas leur
parler de tes problèmes à tes
copines qu'est-ce qui donne envie de
pleurer Nightline c'est une association
étudiante qui a pour mission d'améliorer
la santé mentale des jeunes en
particulier des étudiants et on le fait
en s'appuyant sur un outil qui est
l'aide par les Pères nous ce qu'on fait
en pratique c'est qu'on informe on
dtigmatise on soutient on oriente et on
le fait avec tout un éventail de
dispositifs donc il a la ligne d'écoutes
nocturnes mais on fait aussi des
formations auprès des étudiants dans les
fac on mène des actions de terrain on
mène des campagnes sur les réseaux
sociaux et puis on mène aussi des
actions de ployer
ok ça
marche à toi aussi merci d'avoir appelé
en tout cas sache que tu peux nous
rappeler lorsque tu en ressens le besoin
on est ouvert tous les soirs de 21h à
2h30
passez une bonne soirée au
revoir ça va ouais ouais je pense qu'il
y a un vrai besoin de mettre plus de
moyens donc ça veut dire plus de
psychologue dans les services de santé
étudiants aujourd'hui il y a un
psychologue pour 15000 étudiants donc
c'est 10 fois moins que la
recommandation internationale donc il
s'agit de mettre aussi des moyens ici et
c'est aussi ça qu'il a derrière
Nightline et le projet de la ligne
d'écoute de pouvoir offrir un service
qui est disponible pour tout le monde
pour tous les étudiants euh tous les
soirs et donc idéalement si on veut
pouvoir améliorer la santé mentale des
étudiants bah il faudrait aussi pouvoir
avoir une lighteline dans chacun des
établissements d'enseignement
[Musique]
supérieur c'est le travail sans relâche
le travail euh quotidien les trajet la
précarité
étudiante
c'est des insomnies donc forcément quand
on va en course et on est épuisé
et c'est bah être stressé mais vraiment
à l'idée de tout en fait c'est on peut
plus rien faire sans trembler comme pas
possible dès la première année dès le
premier cours les profs nous disent vous
avez choisi un cursus très difficile il
va falloir s'accrocher votre voisin de
table ne sera pas là dans un
an
des burnout et des dépressions suite à
par exemple trop de travail ou
énormément de pression et d'élitisme de
la part du système de la fac des profs
bah je commence à détester de plus en
plus ce que je fais parce que je vois
que ce domaine me plaît mais il me
consomme trop de temps j'ai arrêté le
sport j'ai arrêté de voir des gens je me
concentr vraiment sur mes études parce
que ça prend vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
de
temps les études c'est toute ma vie
c'est toute ma vie je le dis parce que
j'ai des parents qui ont investi dans
mes études je suis l'aînée et j'ai trois
sœurs derrière qui euh me voit comme un
exemple en en fin de compte donc je me
dis que je n'ai pas le droit à
l'échec 75 % des pathologies
psychiatriques se déclarent entre 15 et
25 ans donc cet âge cet âge étudiant est
un âge euh qui peut être
particulièrement impacté par des
troubles psychologiques voire des
maladies psychiatriques émergentes sur
cette tranche tâche par exemple la
schizophrénie par exemple le trouble
bipolaire ce sont des pathologies qui
généralement émergent à cet âge là donc
il y a déjà une vulnérabilité un peu
caractéristique de l'âge donc la
question de l'âge dans les troubles de
santé mentale elle est fondamentale en
ce sens que on doit s'intéresser très
tôt à ces problématiques pour la
prévention pour l'éventuel intion et
pour les éventuelles prises en charge ce
afin d'éviter que ça se chronicise en
particulier parce que ça se chronicise
très très bien malheureusement les
troubles de santé
[Musique]
mentale jusque l'âge de 25 ans et
parfois un peu au-delà le cerveau
continue à maturer de différentes
manières mais il continue à maturer il
continue à se transformer et comme il se
transforme il est particulièrement
sensible aux influences de l'environ et
cette plasticité elle se fait pour le
meilleur et pour le
pire ma santé mentale en tant
qu'étudiante c'est la pression le stress
l'angoisse de pas réussir et de pas
arriver au but qu'on s'est fixé ça a été
en 2uxè année que ça a commencé à être
la douche froide c'est-à-dire que il y a
des profs qui ont vraiment commencé à
nous mettre la pression très très très
fort je suis épuisé par toutes ces
années d'études épuisé du manque de
considération qu'on peut recevoir
parfois de certains professeurs et c'est
extrêmement difficile à vivre en ce qui
me concerne le problème c'est que même
si souvent je fais de mon mieux et je
réussis mes études j'aià beaucoup de mal
à faire évacuer la la pression après les
examens après les examens il y a
toujours un moment où je suis malade
pendant une semaine quand ça va pas bien
tu je peux même ne pas sortir pendant
plusieurs jours on peut plus rien faire
vent c'est anxiogène j'en pouvais juste
plus de tout j'avais un ralbol de tout
de tout le monde de la vie jusqu'à un
point où bah malheureusement j'ai fait
cette tentative de suicide l'année
dernière la caractéristique des
étudiants par rapport aux autres non
étudiants c'est le cumul des facteurs de
stress qui arrivent sur ce temps des
études et ces facteurs de stress on les
connaît ce sont les facteurs académiques
et notamment la sélectivité ce sont les
facteurs culturels notamment pour les
étudiants sujettis à la mobilité que ça
soit cette mobilité nationale ou
internationale ce sont des facteurs
économiques la fameuse précarité
étudiante et enfin le moral des
étudiants va être impacté par
l'effondrement on l'a vu pendant le
covid de telle ou telle filière
[Musique]
industrielle la détresse psychologique
qui n'est pas une maladie he la détresse
est un ensemble un syndrome un ensemble
de de signaux peut se traduire sur
différents axes de la vie du sujet
évidemment dans la sphère affective et
émotionnelle avec des idées tristes avec
une morosité une irritabilité mais aussi
dans la sphère somatique physique avec
des troubles du sommeil une fatigue
intense une difficulté à travailler dans
la sphère cognitive et c'est là où ça va
impacter le plus l'étudiant avec avec
une baisse de la concentration de la
mémorisation et évidemment la motivation
qui est le nerf de la guerre c'est le
nerf de l'étudiant la motivation la
projection dans l'avenir et par
définition la dépression c'est une
absence d'anticipation une projection
négative dans l'avenir donc vous voyez
ça va venir directement impacter la vie
étudiante ce qui est plus fréquent
beaucoup plus fréquent chez les
étudiants ce sont des troubles comme les
troubles de l'humeur la dépression
notamment les troubles anxieux qu'on
peut retrouver assez fréquemment
également chez les étudiants les
troubles des conduites alimentaires par
exemple qui peuvent aussi émerger à cet
âge-là et puis un trouble dont on parle
assez peu mais qui peut concerner pas
mal d'étudiants surtout à l'heure où on
parle beaucoup des
violences sexiste et sexuel c'est le
trouble de stress
post-traumatique
[Musique]
et qu'est-ce que tu en as pensé de ce
qu'elle t'a
dit d'accord et pourquoi pourquoi tu
étais pas
rassuré et avec tes parents ça se
passait
[Musique]
comment et tu penses que ils auraient
réagi comment si si tu avais décié de le
enarler et ces interdits dont tu me
parlais c'était il venaent de
qui en tout cas n'hésite pas à nous
rappeler on est ouvert de 21h à 2h30
tous les soirs je te souhaite une bonne
soirée au
[Musique]
revoir
mais du coup vu que je suis parti à un
moment ça a duré combien de temps ton
appel ça a duré 45 minutes l'idée
générale de l'appel c'était ça portait
sur le thème de de l'image corporelle et
on va dire de santé sexuelle globalement
c'était un peu compliqué parce que il
était il parlait toujours de la même
chose et même quand tu vois j'essayis de
lui parler de enfin j'essayais de
rebondir sur le moindre petit élément de
son passé de ses parents tout ça et ben
il revenait toujours à la même chose en
fait j'avais rien pour me raccrocher à
ce qu'il disait
c'était il me parlait d'interdit dans
son enfance qui avait des répercussions
tu vois à l'heure actuelle mais c'est
tout j'avais pas plus de de choses que
ça voilà il y avait aussi beaucoup de
silence et j'avais l'impression qu'il
était plus gêné par les silence que moi
mais
voilà le concept des Nightline il est né
dans les années 70 àex dans le sud de la
grande brtagne et donc depuis ça a é un
peu partout en Europe et dans le monde
on peut retrouver des night line en donc
au Royaume-Uni en Irlande en Allemagne
en Autriche en Suisse et puis en France
et nous on est aussi en lien avec des
étudiants belges motivés pour pouvoir
monter une première nighteline en
Belgique le problème de la santé mentale
des étudiants il est pas que
franco-fançais dans les les pays où il y
a des études comparables le constat
qu'on fait c'est celui de VO d'avoir vu
doubler le nombre d'étudiants qui
présentent des symptômes dépressifs
entre avant et après le covid donc ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que le constat
qu'on fait en France on le retrouve un
peu partout en
[Musique]
Europe je suis étudiant en droit j'ai 24
ans et j'habite à brine
Lecomte ma santé mentale à moi c'est
clairement pas l'idéal je m rendre
compte en bachel en fait après la
première année j'avais jamais dû
travailler en secondaire donc forcément
j'arrive à l'unif tout content je teste
mes méthodes habituelle et là bom la
première claque tombe he je passe pas la
première franchement ça a commencé avec
le sommeil le peu d'heure que je dormais
c'était pas suffisant mon mon corps
voulait plus se lever il voyait mon
bureau Mon lit Mon lit mon bureau donc
il y avait plus que ça en tête ça
travaillit constamment mon corps qui
arrivait plus à faire des simples choses
he même à mon pc parfois ça devenait une
épreuve
incommenurable mon corps m'a lâché à
part dormir j'ai rien su
[Musique]
faire bah je commence à détester de plus
en plus ce que je fais j'ai plus le
temps de rien faire j'ai vraiment plus
de vie sociale à un moment donné j'en
pouvais juste plus de tout j'avais un
rball de tout de tout le monde de la vie
jusqu'à un point où malheureusement j'ai
fait cette tentative de suicide l'année
dernière
on n prépare jamais à la réalité on vend
en fait en tout cas endroit c'est comme
ça on vend le ok mais il y a le succès
de l'avocat à côté et en fait le succès
de l'avocat c'est un parcours du
combattant parce que on pousse les gens
en disant mais voilà c'est censé ouvrir
plein de portes et là je vois toutes les
portes se refermées petit à petit et
puis ce qui m'angoisse aussi c'est le
fait que bah le monde va
pas le suicide c'est un problème majeur
de santé publique pour
lequel il est possible d'agir c'està
dire qu'on peut éviter le suicide le
suicide c'est 9000 morts chaque
[Musique]
année on peut penser au 3114 bien sûr
hein le numéro national de prévention du
suicide il peut y avoir des dispositifs
comme euh les sentinelles c'est-à-dire
des personnes des étudiants des des
pères aidentss qui sont vraiment repérés
comme ressources dans leur milieu pour
aller discerner lescrit suicidaire il y
a des dispositifs pour accompagner les
personnes qui ont fait une tentative de
suicide en particulier les jeunes et ce
qu'il faut rappeler c'est que la
prévention du suicide c'est la
responsabilité de chacun le
professionnel le bénévole le citoyen le
politique le décideur on a tous notre
notre rôle à
jouer
c'était en chat suicide
immédiia sauf que quand j'ai proposé
d'appeler les secoursah la personne n
pas voulu et après elle répondait très
peu ensuite du coup je l'ai redirigé à
sa demande vers l'annuaire qu'on a
étudiant mais après par elle répondait
très
[Musique]
peu ensuite elle m'a un petit peu parlé
des raisons qui l'a poussé à vouloir
mourir et après elle a plus répondu et
enfin tu te sembles comment par rapport
au fait que qu'elle allit plus ou moins
arrêter de te répondre bah ça m'a pas
mal inquiété pendant le pendant le
chat parce que forcément mon esprit me
disait mais genre qu'est- qu'est-ce qui
se passe est-ce que ça y est elle va
plus
répondre
alors ça peut arriver que du coup les
personnes nous parlent de suicide et
dans ce cas-là effectivement ça va ça va
attirer notre attention et on va
proposer par exemple d'appeler les
secours quand on appelle les secours
effectivement on est obligé de briser
l'anonymat mais on va prévenir justement
la la plant ou la plante que il va y
avoir une rupture d'anonymat parce que
en fait si on n pas les informations
nécessaires les secours peuvent pas
après intervenir donc c'est c'est le
seul cas où il y a y a a sortie
[Musique]
d'anonyme al je suis ici depuis euh
presque une
semaine première chose que je fais c'est
d'aller au poste des infirmiers pour
prendre mon traitement du jour et très
souvent du coup c'est aussi mon premier
contact social que
j'ai
[Musique]
bonjour bien dormi ça a été
ouais ça
ouais la clinique fondro est un hôpital
psychiatrique à hule dans le sud de de
Bruxelles et euh l'unité 1 dans laquelle
je travaille est unité dédiée
spécialement aux jeunes adultes entre 18
et 30 ans il y a plusieurs types de
pathologies qu'on peut rencontrer ici
donc les premières décompensations
psychiatriques qui peuvent être à la
fois des bouffées délirantes des
tableaux dépressifs des crises
suicidaires des des addictions
importantes qui les qui les mettent
souvent en en retrait de la société en
repli chez eux et puis tout ce qui est
aussi crise existentielle crise de sens
crise familiale aussi euh qui fait qu'à
un moment ces jeunes qui sont n pas le
logement mais trouvent ici un un asile
entre guillemets même si le mot est un
peu galvodé mais un asile où ils peuvent
se se poser se reposer en tout cas et
dans un endroit un peu neutre pour pour
repenser un peu leur projet de
[Musique]
vie je fais des études de droit en
bachelier et je vais être diplômé alors
en
2024 je pense que mes études ont eu un
impact sur ma santé mentale absolument
moi personnellement j'ai tout remis en
question même mes études je les ai remis
en question en me disant et en fait je
sais même pas pourquoi je fais ces
études à force de rester seul ben on
commence à se faire des idées on
commence à se dire que qu'on va pas pour
forcément savoir réussir ces études
aussi enfin il y a vraiment eu plein de
questionnements et à un moment donné je
voyais juste que seulement avoir une
psychologue et avoir des des des séances
des
consultations prendre une pilule chaque
matin était juste pas suffisant en fait
je voyais vraiment qu'il y avait j'avais
besoin d'être dans une institution en
fait pour retrouver une hygiène de vie
qu'on me mette vraiment une structure
une une
routine et qu'on se focalise vraiment
là-dessus que ce soit un peu une pause
dans la vie parce que c'est comme ça que
je le vis tout simplement que j'ai
l'impression que ma vie est en pause et
que à ce momentlà on est juste en
hôpital hospitalisé et on pense
seulement ben comment je me sens
aujourd'hui et et je voyais vraiment que
c'était nécessaire parce que si je ne
rentrais pas en fait j'allais vraiment
faire quelque chose de beaucoup plus
grave je sais pas si je me sens
forcément mieux je dirais que je me sens
plus en paix
euh ce que j'espère
c'est
d'avoir pris le temps
justement d'aller creuser en moi d'aller
voir en fait d'où viennent tous ces
traumatismes j'essaie de faire un
équilibre entre les deux entre ma santé
et mes études et du coup je pense que
c'est vraiment mon premier objectif de
pouvoir franchir ce cap là je pense que
en sortant d'ici je ne vais pas être 100
% guéri ou à 100 % de
nouveau en forme ou quoi que ce soit
mais je pense que du moins il y aurait
quand même quelques petits trucs que
j'aurais que j'aurais réglé des choses
qui seraient plus claires pour
moi je m'appelle margaot j'ai 26 ans et
j'ai fait une licence de
japonais j'ai passé plusieurs mois au
Japon et en fait ça a ét un déclencheur
pour moi justement pour commencer une
fac de japonais et reprendre les études
après ça et du coup je suis rentrée et
la première année j'étais absolument
passionnée par tout ce que tout ce que
j'apprenais je travaille avec plaisir je
restais jusqu'à 21h à la bibliothèque le
soir et enfin je sortais avec un grand
sourire et ça a été en 2uxè année que ça
a commencé à être la douche
froide il y a des profs qui ont vraiment
commencé à nous mettre la pression très
très fort il y a eu ce côté extrêmement
compétitif qui a été mis en place et il
y a des gens qui ne supportent pas ça du
tout j'ai vraiment littéralement fait
une dépression et un burnout parce que
j'arrivais j'arrivais vraiment plus à
suivre j'avais plus de vie et je vivais
mal d'avoir plus de vie ce qui n'était
pas le cas en première année je suis
allée en parler à un de mes profs
préférents que j'appréciais beaucoup à
ce moment-là euh donc je lui ai dit que
ça allait pas et il m'a répondu assez
sereinement
ah dans tous les cas en L2 où il y a 15
% des étudiants japonais qui sont qui
sont en dépression on le
sait tous les ans il y a plusieurs
suicides ils s'en ventent pas mais on le
sait quand
même je me dis que je suis fière
justement d'avoir réussi à à passer
au-dessus de tout ça parce que bah tout
le monde n'a pas cette
chance
bonsoir ici je t'écoute
[Musique]
OK et c'est quoi exactement ton problème
de
santé d'accord
ouais
ouais je comprends c'est le simple fait
de sortir qui te met chos ou c'est ce
que ça ce que ça engendre c'estàd le
déplacement et tout
ça
h comment son tes sens ça va ça va
vraiment il y avait un rapport très
bienveillant donc bien c'était quelqu'un
d'assez touchant de très gentil l'appel
a pas duré h longtemps il a duré une
trentaine de minutes parce qu'en fait
avait juste besoin d'exprimer enfin
juste de parler un petit peu de sa
situation même à la fin elle me l'a dit
que c'était assez catartique de pouvoir
juste sortir les informations de sa tête
juste de les transmettre et de pouvoir
passer à autre chose parce que elle
souffre d'une maladie qui lui pourruit
la vie h et du coup elle se retrouve
très seule elle avait vraiment besoin
d'en parler
ok le malêtre étudiant est très ancien
les différentes enquêtes
épidémiologiques menées par les mutuells
étudiantes puis ultérieurement par
l'Observatoire de la vie étudiante ont
montré déjà avant le covid 20 % de
détresse psychologique puis 25 % de
détresse
psychologique du fait des cumules de
facteurs de stress tous ces facteurs-l
contribuent à la détresse universitaire
qui n'a pas été prise en compte
suffisamment par les pouvoirs publics
depuis le rapport voquè qui date de 2006
finalement rien n'a été vraiment mis en
œuvre de manière importante pour la
santé étudiante il a fallu attendre le
notre gouvernement actuel et le séisme
du covid pour que des moyens
substantiels soient délivrés au regard
d'une souffrance qui est monté jusqu'à
43 % de détresse psychologique en juin
2021 septembre 2021 encore donc
largement au sortir du
[Musique]
covid
la crise du covid on sait a été
particulièrement vulnérabilisante au
plan de la santé mentale pour la
population générale pour les jeunes en
particulier elle a fait un peu un effet
loupe il y a véritablement un avant et
un après
mars 2020 dans la mesure
où les étudiants en particulier les
jeunes en général ont été très très
sévèrement impactés par la crise covid
la privation de socialité chez les
jeunes dont chez les étudiants c'est
quelque chose de cataclysmique c'est un
moment où on construit sa vie
relationnelleù on en a vraiment besoin
où on a généralement beaucoup de
relations beaucoup de sorties où on va
beaucoup dans des lieux présentiels pour
avoir des cours des
formations avoir supprimé tout ça ça a
eu un impact euh absolument
[Musique]
énorme comme tout étudiant je pense que
mes études ont beaucoup d'influence sur
ma santé mentale il y a beaucoup de
stress qui est là il y a beaucoup de de
doutes il y a beaucoup aussi de doutes
non seulement pour les études actuelles
mais pour ce qu'elle me per permettront
de faire plus
tard pendant la période de covid ce qui
a été le plus dur pour moi je pense que
ça a été vraiment l'isolation c'était
vraiment le moment où on est seul avec
soi-même donc mon premier confinement je
l'ai vécu je l'ai vécu essenciellement
dans ma
chambre pendant cette période je ne suis
pas du tout sorti j'ai acheté beaucoup
de Lego je montais des legos dans ma
chambre mais je ne suis pas sorti du
tout à l'extérieur pas du tout du tout
du tout j'ai vraiment ressenti une
grande
solitude cette isement oui a pesé sur ma
santé mental parce que ne sortant plus
et prenant un peu moins soin de moi mais
avait les moments de doute de se de se
voir dans le miroir et de quand on n pas
bien on se voit encore plus lait si je
peux dire que ce qu'on est réellement
donc oui cela a énormément joué sur la
santé mental de rester enfermé de ne
presque parler à personne parce que même
si j'avais quelques d' amis à qui je
pouvais envoyer des messages ben ne
sortant pas j'avais pas grand chose à
dire et on fait vite le tour d'une
journée enfermé chez
soi en été 2021 suite au deuxième
confinement j'avais une amie ma
meilleure amie qui elle a vécu la crise
de covid encore beaucoup plus fort que
n'importe qui je pense dans mon
entourage et qui a préférait faire une
bêtise
et quitter ce monde enfin c'est une
jolie jolie façon de le dire mais
elle avait beaucoup de doutes en elle
c'était une période qui était très
difficile c'est une période où elle
s'est senti très seule où je pense que
aucun message virtuel n'aurait suffi à
l'idée je pense qu'elle avait vraiment
besoin que la vie soit comme elle était
avant de pouvoir sortir de pouvoir
changer ses idées mais elle elle est
restée enfermée chez elle ce qui lui a
fait broyer encore plus du noir c'est
cette période là qui elle l'a enfoncé je
[Musique]
pense les étudiants dont la socialité a
été complètement supprimé de même que la
possibilité de se projeter dans leurs
études ont véritablement vécu ça comme
un traumatisme un traumatisme
c'est-à-dire quelque chose qui effracte
le psychisme et qui est susceptible
d'attenter à la vie en tout cas
tellement gravement à la qualité de la
vie que ça devient difficile de se
projeter dans une vie future
et donc les étudiants les jeunes ont
davantage que d'autres catégories de la
population ces états de stress
post-traumatique c'est une chose qui est
inédite dans l'histoire de l'humanité
l'état de stress post-traumatique c'est
quelque chose qui survient quand on
risque de mourir soi-même quand on voit
quelqu'un mourir qu'on est pris dans un
attentat là on a des gens toute une
population qui s'est retrouvé dans cet
état
traumatisé en raison des confinements
qu'ils ont subis et on le sait parce
qu'il le disent c'est-à-dire quand on
leur
demande qu'est-ce qui dans ce qui s'est
passé dans cette crise a été le plus
traumatogène pour vous il y a la peur de
mourir il y a la peur que mes proches
meurent et il y a le risque d'un
prochain
[Musique]
confinement je m'appelle Amina j'ai 24
ans je suis étudiante en science
politique cette année et je suis à
l'université de versaill sa
Quentin ma santé mentale en tant
qu'étudiante c'est la pression le stress
l'angoisse de pas réussir et de pas
arrivé au but qu'on s'est fixé il y a eu
beaucoup de stress beaucoup de pression
les premières années enfin la première
année la seconde il y a eu le covid et
et là c'était vraiment très compliqué de
de suivre parce que du coup on est isolé
on est seul on est plus dans dans
l'élément qu'on est en train de
construire il y a eu le premier
confinement parce qu'on était terrorisé
par le par le covid et que on se rendait
compte de de ce qui se passait autour de
nous et que le covid voilà c'était grave
et qu'il fallait s'isoler mais très
rapidement on était surchargé par
beaucoup de travail à la maison donc les
profs nous mettaient la pression en
étant à la maison je pense qu'il pensait
qu'on ne faisait rien alors qu'en
réalité on avait une double charge de
travail et donc ça c'était très
compliqué sur ma santé mentale
oui j'ai eu un début d'ulcère à
l'estomac j'ai passé parfois des
semaines sans vouloir me lever sans
vouloir faire quoi que ce soit et avoir
aussi la pression qu'il faut que je me
lève et que je travaille pour réussir et
on se dit aussi qu'on a pas besoin
d'aide que que la seule solution ce
serait de réussir pour aller mieux et et
on met de côté tout ce qui nous arrive
en ce moment
même ils ont été beaucoup stigmatisés
ils ont été désignés comme un des
éléments majeurs de la circulation
donc du coup ça a eu un effet terrible
sur leur santé mentale qui s'est très
rapidement vu dans les données on a vu
exploser les troubles anxieux les
troubles dépressifs les troubles du
sommeil donc tous les gens qui tous les
jeunes tous les étudiants qui se sont
retrouvés dans avec des troubles mentaux
de ce type en raison de cette
période risque d' d'en subir les
conséquences pendant très longtemps du
simple point de vue de la santé mentale
par ailleurs pour beaucoup leur C s de
formation a été très gravement altéré et
ça ça aura un impact sur toute leur vie
ça veut dire qu'en fait on a engendré
des conséquences pour plusieurs
décennies donc on peut pas du tout
considérer que le problème est est
terminé même malheureusement on pourrait
avoir tendance à considérer qu'il
[Musique]
commence il y a forcément des appels qui
restent à des degrés différents et nous
à Nightline on a des moyens aussi
différent de pouvoir les extérioriser le
premier niveau c'est euh c'est c'est
débriefing qu'on fait à Chud tout de
suite après avoir raccroché ou dans les
quelques minutes qui suivent et qu'on
partage avec les autres bénévoles qui
sont en permanence avec nous ça c'est un
peu le le le premier degré
d'extériorisation ensuite on a ce qu'on
appelle les réunions de partage c'est
des réunions qui ont lieu une fois par
mois et euh qui rassemblent entre 5 et
10 bénévoles et qui sont encadrés par
une psychologue et pendant ces réunions
de partage l'objectif c'est justement de
reparler de ces appels qui restent avec
nous parce que les thématiques sont
lourdes et qu'elles nous ont marqué
parce que on s'est senti
particulièrement en difficulté pendant
l'appel pour x ou y raison ces réunions
elles sont obligatoires pour tous les
bénévoles qui prennent des appels et
elles sont mensuelles donc on n pas le
droit de prendre d'appel pendant un mois
si on a pas fait sa réunion le mois
précédent en parler à la famille et aux
amis c'est justement pas possible dans
le cadre de Nightline parce que le rôle
de benévole est anonyme cet anonymat il
est au premier plan pour les appelants
eux ne doivent pas dévoiler de
d'information sur eux mais en fait elle
est valable aussi pour nous nous les
bénévoles on doit pas révéler à notre
entourage qu'on est bénévolent à
Nightline c'est c'est c'est une partie
de notre quotidien qui secrète pour un
tas de raisons l'une d'entre elles c'est
de ne pas projeter d'identité sur ce
bénévole qui peut nous répondre sur ce
service d'écoute pour ne pas peut-être
décourager certains de nos proches qui
pourraent avoir envie d'appeler mais qui
ne le font pas parce qu'ils auraient
vend de notre engagement donc pour ces
raisons et pour encore plein d'autres on
peut pas partager justement ce qui se
passe en permanence avec nos
proches
c'est un microcuseci c'est c'est dans la
vraie vie ça peut pas se passer comme ça
en tout cas pour moi de mon côté ça ne
se passe pas comme ça ma journée elle
est faite je fais les choses que j'ai à
faire et j'ai pas le temps de m'occuper
de ma santé mentale et parfois on va pas
forcément trouver la personne à qui
parler ou sentir en confiance et ça
aussi enfin moi personnellement j'ai
vraiment beaucoup mal à parler de moi
surtout quand ça va pas bien et c'est
vraiment difficile de faire parvenir le
message de là ça va pas j'ai besoin j'ai
besoin d'aide c'est que peut-être la
société a échoué à fournir suffisamment
de ressources comme vous le nomiez que
s'il y avait justement plus de choses en
ambulatoire ça permettrait de maintenir
son son rythme de vie son emploi tout en
ayant une place pour prendre soin de soi
et que finalement ça soit pas de l'ordre
du sacrifice de prendre soin de soi
c'est super dur de faire ça à
l'extérieur moi j'ai
tenté ça fait 3 ou 4 ans que je tente de
faire ça qu'à l'extérieur et je n'y
arrive pas en tout cas en psychiatrie
c'est c'est bouché de chez boucher
complètement donc il y a cette réalité
là aussi c'est pas que le bon vouloir de
la personne déjà qu'on est fatigué
émotionnellement parlant et que on n pas
spécialement envie de s'en sortir parce
qu'on est dans une boucle mais en plus
de ça si si tout est bouché de tous les
côtés c'est pas possible
[Musique]
quoi
c'est un sentiment très très particulier
ça fait vraiment très bizarre parce que
je pense que c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on va chez quelqu'un et qu'on dit bah
ouais moi en
fait j'ai envie de mourir ou j'ai pas
l'énergie pour aller faire mes courses
de me lever du lit et cetera et que
l'autre dit ah bah ouais moi aussi
franchement ce sont vraiment des sujets
en fait qui sont hyper hyper pas hyper
mais je dirais qu' sont qu'on entend pas
très souvent dans la vie de tous les
jours et ici en fait justement on arrive
vraiment à en parler entre patient et
c'est complètement
normal moi et ma génération on se pose
aussi vraiment énormément la question de
qu'est-ce qui va être le futur et du
coup on est pleinement dans nos études
on se dit avec le rechauffement
climatique on sait même pas comment le
monde va être dans dans 30 50 ans et ça
crée vraiment une grosse grosse anxiété
quoi ça crée vraiment une une crise
existentielle tout simplement de se dire
mais en fait là je suis en train de
faire des études est-ce que ça vaut
vraiment le coup l'anxiété elle est là
quoi
[Musique]
quand on dit écho anxiété on a tout de
suite tendance à considérer ça comme un
trouble anxieux et ça risque d'avoir
cette conséquence que on va avoir
tendance à considérer que si les jeunes
sont écoonxeux c'est parce qu'ils ont
des problématiques qui leur sont propres
non les jeunes et toute l'humanité
développent des émotions par rapport à
ce risque qui sont légitimes qui sont
sains et qui lorsqu'ils ne deviennent
pas inhibant par parce qu'ils sont trop
intenses génère de l'action de la colère
de la révolte du coup c'est même plus de
l'anxiété c'est de la peur parce que
l'anxiété c'est quelque chose qui est là
par rapport à un danger futur un peu
incertain mais là on est dans un danger
concret qui est actuel c'est de la peur
quand on a pas peur face à un danger
c'est pas qu'on est courageux c'est
qu'on est
inconscient je m'appelle Zinedine j'ai
24 ans je fais actuellement un un Master
2 de droit à l'université Paris
nan on va dire que je vais très mal
parce que je suis épuisé par toutes ces
années d'études et c'est extrêmement
difficile à vivre c'estàdire que tous
les jours c'est je me rends à la fac la
boule au ventre je vais au à mon
alternance en cabinet d'avocat la boule
au
ventre alors les études ça apporte quand
même personnellement mais il y a quand
même une forme de déception au bout du
tunnel parce que il y a pas de
transition c'est c'estàd qu'on finit
l'université ensuite on est balancé dans
le grand bain et on se rend compte que
c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on nous a
présenté au début et je pense
personnellement que je ne suis pas fait
pour le monde dans lequel on me balance
aujourd'hui il y a un contexte qui est
très particulier il y a eu la crise
covid il y a eu même le mouvement des
gilets jaunes on pourrait presque
l'inclure l'inflation la guerre toutes
ces chosesl qui sont très difficiles à
vivre je pense que de manière plus
générale ça pèse sur toute la société en
réalité mais les étudiants ils ont une
difficulté supplémentaire c'est que eux
ils sont déjà pour certains dans une
grande précarité et ils doivent en plus
de cela continuer à rester motivés
pendant leurs études et c'est je pense
que c'est ça aussi le plus difficile
rester motivé alors que l'avenir est
totalement incertain en réalité c'est
plus dur de se projeter aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'il y a une dizaine d'années
parce que les problèm clatiques sont
beaucoup plus mises en avant le
réchauffement climatique c'est devenu un
sujet de tous les jours les
problématiques économiques c'est devenu
un sujet de tous les jours le chômage
les violences sexist sexuelles il y a un
un un climat ambiant qui en fait est
probablement plus anxiogène aujourd'hui
pour les jeunes et qui est accentué par
la pression des examens l'isolement de
la famille faire des études c'est bien
mais on va aussi avoir besoin d'aller
plus loin dans comment est-ce qu'on se
sent bien où est-ce qu'on veut aller
beaucoup plus que gagner un gros salaire
ça va vraiment être comment est-ce que
je me sens bien dans mes études pour
aller bien dans ma vie professionnelle
et on s'est rendu compte que de plus en
plus les étudiants et les étudiantes
avaient envie d'avoir un bon cadre de
vie avant d'avoir un cadre de vie
luxueux les sociétés sont éminemment
régulières fiable structuré prévisible
pour leurs membres donc bien évidemment
quand on s'engage par exemple dans des
études on s'attend à ce que le métier
auquel on se forme existe encore dans 5
ans dans 10 ans quand on projette une
famille on s'attend à ce qu'il a encore
une planète dans 15 ans pour les enfants
qu'on va faire et ce sont des
régularités extrêmement puissantes
extrêmement structurantes non seulement
de la société mais aussi des psychismes
individuels et tout ceci a été disloqué
et donc les jeunes sont pris dans ça
aujourd'hui à une époque de leur vie où
leur psychisme leur fonctionnement
relationnel et leur implication dans la
sociétés sont encore en
construction donc il y a cette dimension
de ça va se construire sur quelque chose
de pas stable et de pas prévisible et là
c'est la base des graves grave graves
troubles
mentaux j'ai 21 ans et je suis
actuellement en 2e année de buut
carrière sociale parcours animation
sociale et socioculturelle à liité de
tourcoin alors la santé mentale c'est
compliqué selon les jours il y a déjà
bah tout ce qui est vie quotidienne donc
c'està dire quand on est étudiant et
précaire bah savoir comment bah se loger
payer le loyer payer tout ce qui est à
côté les frais quotidiens comme bah tout
ce qui est transport la nourriture enfin
les courses et cetera plus bah après
qu'on a pas de soutien
de de sa famille proche comme les
parents c'est vrai que c'est compliqué à
gérer au
quotidien avec mes parents ce qui s'est
passé c'est que bah je suis LGBT et eux
ils
ont pas bien pris la la nouvelle et du
coup ça fait 3 ans à cause de ça que je
ne les vois plus et que j'ai pas le
droit de voir mon petit
frère j'avais aucun revenu parce que ben
j'avais pas le droit à la Bourse donc
j'ai dû demander une pension alimentaire
même si ça a été long parce que bah
vivre quand étudiant c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué sans ressources
financières et c'est vrai que quand on
peut pas en étant étudiant être suivi
par exemple par un psychologue parce que
ça coûte cher et que on voit les délais
pour les bureaux d'aide ou pour des fois
les psychiatres qui pe peuvent être
remboursés par la Sécurité Sociale
euh c'est compliqué des fois on a
tendance plus à ne pas être suivi et bah
laisser tomber parce que bah c'est
épuisant de en plus des études de devoir
chercher de devoir s'investir encore sur
un autre plan c'est décourageant c'est
dé en France on a des vraies difficultés
autour de la santé
mentale en ce sens que dans les par
exemple centres médicau-psychologiques
il y a des listes d'attentes qui sont
importants et par ailleurs les services
de santé universitaires probablement ne
sont pas assez pourvus notamment en en
psychologue ou en professionnel de la
psychiatrie les fils d'attente
aujourd'hui pour les jeunes que ce soit
en ville que ce soit à l'université dans
dans les services universires que ce
soit à l'école les fils d'attente pour
accéder à des soins psychiques elles
sont lunaires lunaire c'est 6 mois dans
certains endroits en France très
défavorisés c'est 18 mois autant dire
que ça n'a aucun sens quand on a un
problème de de santé mentale sérieux euh
même pas forcément sévère mais déjà
sérieux c'est c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
maintenant ça va patron ça va bien ça va
ça va on dit quoi on dit rien rien il
rien ok allez tu as pas encore rangé
euh là là et quoi tu as la flemme c'est
ça non non je faisais une sieste
ah allez à tout à
l'heure c'est Monsieur bikay pour le
tour de 16h ça va ouais qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait
aujourd'hui
euh grand chose comment ça pas
grand-chose J's tuas pas fait d'activité
aujourd'hui tu as pas été en activité
fin de journée fin de journée
ou il est 16h ou ou mais je vais voir
mon père deabord ah d'accord papa
d'abord et puis l'activité après
[Musique]
ça va bon allez à tout à
l'heure
rentrer quand
même oh
[Musique]
oh ça va
maman
[Musique]
donc la bemoiselle elle dort il faut
quand même vérifier qu'elle
respire
[Musique]
je m'appelle oui j'ai 25 ans je suis
sénégalaise je suis venue en France
après mon bac en 2017 je suis partie à
tour où j'ai fait des études de droit et
là je suis revenue sur Paris pour
continuer mes
études ma première année à tour a été un
peu éprouvante parce que je connaissais
pas la ville cétait c'est la première
fois que j'ai commencé à vivre seule à
aller faire mes courses toute seule à
payer mon loyer et entre l'université et
ma vie
sociale j'étais très vite fatiguée et il
a fallu que je me retrouve aux urgences
que le médecin me demande ce que je
faisais dans la vie et que je lui dise
que je suis étudiante en droit que je
lui dise clairement que j'avais pas
envie de me réveiller que là je me rends
compte de de ce que enfin de ce qui est
en train de devenir ma
vie j'avais pas envie de me réveiller
parce que enfin c un un peu compliqué
entre la fac entre ma vie sociale entre
enfin j'avais l'impression d'être sur
tous les fronts et que j'avais pas de
résultats j'ai pris des médicaments et
j'ai pris 20 kg et ça ne m'a pas aidé ça
ne m'a pas aidé parce que derrière enin
on perd on perd on perd confiance en soi
on se trouve plus
bellefin mes habits ne m'allaient plus
enfin tout le monde me disait que j'ai
pris du poids comme si je ne me voyais
pas devant la glace chaque
matin si français doit doit être bien
l'étudiant étranger doit être excellent
pour s'en sortir et on est constamment
sous pression donc va falloir alliier
vaoir réussir ses études parce que si on
réussit pas la préfecture ne va pas
renouveler son ton titre de séjour et
derrière faut avoir une une vie sociale
faut s'en sortir faut trouver un
logement décent faut manger à sa fin
voilà faut vivre tout simplement comme
j'ai l'habitude de dire alors que vivre
à un coup en France vivre c'est pas
évident vivre c'est pas parce qu'il y a
vivre et vivre il suffit pas de rest IR
pour dire qu'on vit quand on est
étudiant et qu'on va pas bien on n'est
pas seul ça c'est un point important
alors on a certes dit qu'il y avait des
difficultés qu' avait des lattentes et
pour autant on s'organise les
professionnels sont mobilisés et donc
les étudiants ne sont pas seuls il y a
énormément d'initiatives qui ont été
mises en place en paèire à paèire donc
des étudiants et des étudiantes pour les
étudiants et les étudiantes et c'est
vers ça que nous on pense queil faut
aussi voilà encourager ces initiatives
là aider les les structures à se mon à
se professionnaliser à aller dans la
bonne direction puisque l'État et
l'université ne peuvent pas combler tous
les manques ça coûte énormément d'argent
mais les étudiantes et les étudiants ont
envie de se mobiliser d'aider et de
faire au mieux au quotidien et parfois
nuit et jour pour certaines
[Musique]
activités tu imaginis que ça se
passerait
comment c'est c'est quelque chose qui te
dérange
[Musique]
moi je t'en prie hésite pas à rappeler
si si tu en as
envie je t'en prie passe une bonne
soirée merci au
[Musique]
revoir tu veux débriefer du coup
yes du coup ça a duré 2h donc le temps
maximal c'est été enfin il y a eu plein
de thématiques qui ont été abordé il y a
eu la
dépression les relations familial suite
à un coming
out
et le regard des gens par rapport à la
dépression du coup dans le dans la
thématique et et que en fait la personne
pouvait pas enfin se sentait pas
légitime de dire à ses proche qu'elle
avait une dépression et du coup enfin
j'aiis il y a des gens qui sont pas
encore
enfin qui qui ont toujours pas
conscience des enjeux de santé mentale
et que oui bah ça existe et que non
c'est pas enfin c'est pas des fous ça ma
fait vachement de peine parce que
c'était une personne qui avait un genre
une histoire assez lourde de par la
réaction de de sa famille face à son
comingout et tout donc c'était pas enfin
ouais j'étais un peu triste pour pour
cette personne mais à la fin la personne
était contente d'avoir pu parler donc
c'était chouette et elle m'a dit à la
fin que bah elle comptait reconacter
Nightline parce que ça l'avait vraiment
aidé donc donc ça fait plaisir parfois
on a l'impression que les jeunes ne
veulent pas s'engager ou ne font rien
pour la société on entend beaucoup ce
discours nous on voit plutôt l'inverse
une vraie volonté de prendre acte que
voilà tout ne va pas bien mais on n pas
envie d'être la génération d'après il y
a vraiment un besoin chez les étudiantes
et étudiant de se dire on est acteur et
actrice déjà maintenant on se rend
compte que il y a besoin d'agir et on
agit les étudiants de manière général
même s'ils sont réellement en difficulté
pour eux-mêmes dans leur vie actuelle ne
sont pas dans une vision décliniste ni
catastrophique du monde ce sont des
jeunes qui restent très engagés dans un
avenir sur lequel ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir les moyens d'intervenir du fait
de leur formation du fait leur alliance
avec la science du fait leur niveau
d'ambition du fait leur vitalité
et je pense que cette vision des
clinistes c'est assez loin c'est plus
une vision leurs parents ou leurs
grands-parents peut-être mais c'est
assez loin leur préoccupation du moment
les jeunes ils sont
vraiment dans une envie d'agir et ils
agissent déjà on n plus l'idée de on
fera plus tard mais vraiment le on sait
faire on a fait des choses maintenant il
faut aussi nous laisser la place ce
besoin de d'avoir une place qui leur
soit considérée et que on leur dise pas
vous ferez plus tard mais ils peuvent
faire maintenant et ils ont envie de
faire
maintenant
[Applaudissements]